uh you've had a few opinions about
bitcoin over the years what are your
thoughts about bitcoin today its role
in the global financial system and just
in human society in general
well the evolution of bitcoin over the
years is one of the things that
has
um
influenced changes in my view
um
it
has proven itself
um something like 10 11 years ago
imagine the programming of this and
here's the you throw it out and that's
the idea it has not been hacked
it has um
um operated it is built it has come an
amazing way
over that 11 years to be
maybe
probably the most excited topic
among a lot of people
um and has been used and and is now
has obtained you know the status of
having imputed value
at the same time it is one of those
assets
that is an alternative money i think
we're entering an era
where um there's going to be a
competition of monies
um
because of the printing of fiat money
and the
depreciated value there will be a
competition of monies
um and bitcoin is part of that
competition but there'll be many monies
not just crypto monies but there'll be
central bank crypto monies
but there'll be different kinds of
monies
and even monies
are things that you buy and sell
nfts can become a money
a type of money you own it and it's an
investment and you could say i'd rather
own it than own uh bitcoin
has ray dalia bought any nfts not yet
okay
um
but um only only just because like i i
definitely want to buy nfts to just
experience them you know like i think
think i should produce one yeah and i
should uh i should have asked that have
you made it have you mentioned an empty
you probably should just to know what
it's like yeah that's right this stuff
is happening yeah this stuff is real
okay and how it operates but like all
new real things
um some are gonna go and some gonna you
know it's like in the internet in the
year 2000
um you know pets.com could have been a
great but babypets.com doesn't make it
and who knows that's the beauty of the
competitive system that will evolve and
some things will be treasured and some
things will be uh trashed
so um
but when i look at it um i think we are
in an environment of you know what is an
alternative money a money has two
purposes a medium of exchange and a
storehold of wealth
and we are looking for
um and it's portable
and you can and it's best if it's
recognized in other countries
um so gold is one of those so i look at
it as an alternative gold
but i look at a number of things as
alternative gold
and i think that and i think and gold is
still my favorite
because of certain qualities for example
um you can't trace it in in bitcoin you
can trace who owns it where it's going
and and so on governments can't have
that ability to trace it and so on a
gold piece of coin it's it's not
connected i think not connected has
benefits particularly in a world where
maybe connections can be more risky
um so um and then also gold has been um
for many thousands of years universally
recognized as a source of money and
central banks it's the third largest uh
source of money in central bank reserves
and i don't think bitcoin is going to
serve those types of purposes and so on
so for various reasons i prefer gold to
the other but it's a little bit part of
my mix
you